so let me give you a hypothetical
suppose that you're a parent and you
have a daughter say a teenage daughter
whose room is an absolute mess it just
looks like a bomb went off in there and
you want your daughter to clean your
room you're trying to sell her on the
idea of cleaning her room what do you do
well you could try to bribe her and that
might work in the short term you could
try to threaten her that might work in
the short term you can try to exhort her
you can try to you know tell her about
the meaning of clean rooms but there's
actually a technique from actually the
counseling literature really
crystallized by a fellow named Mike
pantalon of Yale University called
motivational interviewing and what you
can do more effectively is ask to
irrational questions so let's say that
you have a daughter named Maria and
Maria has a messy room and you want
Maria to clean her room the two
questions you could ask Maria are this
Maria on a scale of 1 to 10 1 meaning
I'm not ready at all 10 meaning I'm
ready to do it right now how ready are
you Maria to clean your room now Maria's
room is a pigsty so she's not going to
give a very she's not going to give you
a 10 or a 9 or even a 5 maybe she'll
give you a 2 okay so she says dad I'm a
2 well here's where the second question
comes in and it's a really interesting
counterintuitive question you say to
Maria okay Maria you're two why didn't
you pick a lower number
now our instincts as parents is to say
as a parent of three kids I have this
instinct very strongly my kid were to
say to me I'm a two I would say why are
you two you should be a nine but you say
why didn't you pick a lower number Maria
so here's what happens Maria has to
explain why she isn't a one okay and so
she says well you know I am 15 and I
probably should get my act together you
know if I had my room cleaner I'd be
able to get to school on time faster and
maybe see my friends a little bit more
you know you and Mom never know where
anything is anyway so I'm kind of
wasting my time asking you to help me
what happens with that second question
why don't you pick a lower number Maria
begins articulating her own reasons for
doing something and this is really axiom
matic in sales and persuasion when
people have their own reasons for doing
something not yours their own reasons
for doing something they believe those
reasons more deeply and adhere to the
behavior more strongly
now suppose Maria says dad on a scale of
one to ten I'm a 1 ok that makes things
a little more complicated but it's
actually a really really important to
understand this if you say to Maria if
Maria says dad I'm a 1 here's what you
say to Maria Maria what can we do to
make you a 2 and what often that does is
this Maria will say well maybe if you
and mom help me for 15 minutes to get
this started maybe if you maybe not set
the table and take out the trash tonight
that would free up some time for me
because usually when people are a 1 it's
often because not because they're purely
obstinate it's because there's some kind
of environmental obstacle in front of
them and if you if someone says there
are 1 find out what that obstacle is try
to make them a 2 and that might give you
some more momentum the the example I
just gave had to do with with parenting
but you can use this more universally
now you can't whip it out at every
single persuasive encounter but you can
use it to persuade your boss you can use
it maybe just persuade a reluctant
prospect in an actual sales encounter
you can you can use it with someone your
neighbor who's resisting moving his
garbage cans or something like that
the key here and again you got to go
back to first principles here the key
here is that we tend to think that
persuasion or motivation is something
that one person does to another and what
the social science tells us very clearly
is that it's really something that
people do for themselves and your job as
a persuader as a motivator is to reset
the context and surface people's own
reasons for doing something because it
works a lot better
you